oh my god I was such a warm introduction
I cannot tell you how thrilled I am to
be here
it just it's I was it wasn't so long ago
I'd like to think that I was in your
shoes and when I was thinking about all
the different things that I wanted to
talk about today so many things came to
mind and eventually I decided that what
I really wanted to be able to share
today is something that I don't think
you're gonna be able to get anywhere
else it's certainly not something that I
was able to find for many many years but
what I want to share today is I want to
talk about what I believe might be the
future steps of your career and I want
to be able to paint a picture I wouldn't
be able to make it real I want to share
with you I'm not gonna be able to
predict all the things that are going to
happen but I want to share with you an
emotional experience of what it's like
to go through all of the different
levels within within an organization
within your career so with that Romney
just gave me the warmest introduction
ever but hi I'm Elaine something that
was emitted originally I grew up on a
goat farm in southwest Missouri my
mother she was a nurse she was a goat
judge and to everyone's surprise I did
not follow in her footsteps but instead
I ended up out here in California
learning how to code graduating with a
degree in symbolic systems from there
went to a company called synaptics
worked on usability human factors
research for scrolling devices and then
in 2005 ended up co-founding Meebo we I
think up in 2009 2010 we had hundreds of
millions of users make lots of funding
and then in 2012 we ended up exiting to
Google and since then I did a lot of
things I did it by saying I did a little
bit of investing I did contributed to
the Wall Street Journal and then more
recently took a totally different turn
which is to bring a bean-to-bar
Chocolate Factory to San Francisco which
has been so much fun so anyway today ok
so today I'm gonna go through and I'm
going to touch upon every single one of
these levels and I want to talk about
where where does this come from
so you know traditional
career traditional career might stand
3040 years and every single one of these
levels might you know you might be at
one of these levels for five ten years
if you're good at it hopefully much much
much longer certainly not a race but the
experience of being a founder is a
unique one and it's so stressful and it
is so intense and essentially when you
start a company you're starting as an
intern our contributor and then within
the next six to 12 to 18 months you are
responsible for basically running
through flying through every single
stage of your organization and defining
hey what is it going to be like to be a
contributor here what is it going to be
like to be a manager here and you might
be in a role for three to four months
and then later on you know you start off
you're in the code you're trying to
develop a future trying to show proof of
concept and then BAM three to four
months later you have to hire a team and
now you have to manage that team and
then BAM three to four months later you
have multiple teams and then you have to
manage across themes and then all of a
sudden BAM you're at the VP level and
you're thinking about strategy and
finally earth your home and you're
trying to predict what's actually going
to happen in an organization with your
organization in three to five years out
happen so so so quickly it's so so so
stressful wouldn't trade it for the
world
but think that that gives you is this
perspective that I think is really
really rare and most of the time when
you're going through these different
levels you don't have the experience of
having them back-to-back so if you ask
somebody hey what's it like what's the
difference between a director and VP you
know it may have been for a VP it may
have been 10 to 15 years since they were
at that level I thought this was super
fascinating and even when I was at
amiibo I was taking notes of my
experiences recording everything I could
because it was just changing so rapidly
and what I want to do today is we're
gonna try something and I'm going to
share with you six stories that I've
hand-picked some of them are mine
they've all been in autumn eyes so don't
assume that these are you know
Engineering has been swapped for design
whatever it is and I think that these
six stories really crystallized what it
is like to be at this level and then
afterwards we're just going to do a
brief like hey what do you feel like
happened in that role what was really
going on and then we're going to BAM
we're
I might have been switching roles every
three to four months you we're going to
be switching roles every I don't know
four to five minutes and then we're
gonna feel what it was like to be the
first day as an intern and then we're
going to end with the last day as a CEO
all good all right so next there are so
many caveats to this so first of all I
am simplifying a thousand things you
know a sales organization is different
than an engineering organization a large
company is different than a small
company there are so many things that I
know that this is not going to be a
perfect simplification but it is one
slice of an organization and I think
that it's still really really
interesting so with that oh this is such
a good one Logan not his real name Logan
oh I love this guy all right it was
probably a year one year two at Nebo and
we wanted to hire our first intern and I
ended up hiring Logan not his real name
who was amazing he was a sophomore he
was taking classes that were far beyond
his years he was super super fun
he had big crazy hair he could recite
like 200 digits of pi in a second I
loved working with him and we said Logan
come onboard and we as a company we were
trying to focus on this very regimented
product roadmap I'm like we know we have
to do we have to deliver we have this
board roadmap and we said but Logan
Logan we have all of these projects that
we can't get to and you know some of
them are like really deep memory
challenges some of them were like
dynamic skinning and we said take your
choice do whatever you want you're here
we're super thrilled to have you take
your pick and so Logan takes our list of
potential projects that we've thought
through through the summer goes through
line by line by line and then he puts
his finger on the hardest project of
them all and just to give some you know
background that the hardest project that
he wanted to work on was pop-out windows
all right so this is back before jquery
even existed this looking we were
working with like really really really
really crusty antiquated browsers we
weren't even sure it was going to work
and he's like that's my project we're
like whoa you know if you say so that's
fine let's just let's just see
how far you get great so week 1 week 1
Logan he is checking in code he's fixing
bugs he's getting himself deep into
depository he's trying to figure out how
things work it's great right
week 2 he's actually like he's like you
know what I think it's time I think I
understand how the code works I think I
understand these libraries I'm gonna
start trying to build a prototype and by
week 3
he actually has a prototype something
that looks like when you hit you know
pop out BAM it's there and we are all
rejoicing we're like whoa like this
could actually happen right week 4 he's
like yeah you know everything's looking
good but I have to figure out some
really deep technical issues wait five I
think he goes on some you know goes to
take a break for the summer comes back
week six he's like okay I got the
technical issues now I just have you
know all of these really tiny bugs and I
think we're good like this is incredible
right like holy cow this feature we're
never expecting to add wasn't on the
roadmap and I'm actually thinking that
Logan can deliver so then we get into
week seven and I'm like a little bit
how's it going what are we gonna build
to check this in witness you know it's
like I'm working on it we're gonna just
got these small bugs and like okay great
next week week eight week nine he's like
you know those small bugs where it's so
small but I'm working on it I think I'm
almost there I think I'm almost there
week nine week ten week eleven week 12
I'm sweating I don't just like Logan
right like if we're gonna do this we've
got to do this right and you know he's
like working on I'm just gonna
documentation I'm making it perfect he
don't mind he's already branched it into
a different you know he's he's taken
away from trunks we still have to merge
all of his code back in gets to Friday
and wake up and he's like okay I'm ready
and I'm like holy cow you're ready and
he had printed out all of his code it
was a 30 page code review on paper and
are his hire team how you know we're
like okay right and we had to review
every single line emerging into trunk
the entire day and for those of you who
are not engineers this is the equivalent
of like I don't know it's like they pull
them I'm doing like open-heart surgery
and then you know it comes to noon and
you're like hey you know what you know
actually you know it's my lunch break I
need to go right and for us it was like
this is Friday he's checking in 30 pages
of code
into a live product and then after 5:00
p.m. we're not gonna see him again
crazy now here's the thing all right
full credit
first of all Logan is amazing I love
Logan if I could hire Logan today I
absolutely would and to his credit
oftentimes when interns come in their
projects may or may not work right but
to Logan's credit like it was a massive
undertaking and you know yes or some
bogs whatever right he checked him 30
lines of code but we actually maintained
that code up until the very very end of
the existence of Nebo it was good code
he did a really really good job and yes
my engineering team you know pulled out
here as a time and they were super super
frustrated but when I look back at it
he knocked it out of the park so then
nine months later you know everybody's
come come to terms wherever we are we're
already moving on I get an email and
it's from Logan and he says Elaine
Elaine how's it going Elaine I'm ready I
want project number two and I had to
write this really really difficult email
which is Logan you are great your code
is great however my team still has PTSD
from the 30 pages of code that you
checked in nine months ago and as much
as I would love to have you here I don't
think I can do it and then time goes by
and Logan says I get this email from him
and keep in mind he was a junior then I
have to say this is one of the most
mature emails I've ever received and he
says Elaine thank you so much I
appreciate the feedback that is a very
very very very valuable lesson and I
wish you all the best and that's where
it was so from that that's our
experience number one when you think
about that experience what do you feel
are the potential mistakes at that level
anybody shout it out I'll repeat it yeah
yes sir other managers I'm the intern
intern yeah I think that it is obviously
killing it the whole time like usually
starting with you and let you know that
where he was so you have no idea where
comes out last month yeah there's still
feedback loop I was checking in with him
but yep yep and there for sure there
were definitely things that I could have
done better as a manager as well but at
the end of the day ya know it's totally
true but you know there there was a
feedback loop it was missing right like
um what else alright so when I think
about that experience
you have some things like number one I
think that you know whoa gun especially
when you're in school you're focusing on
getting the a and you're focusing on how
do I deliver how do I prove myself and
what kind of drifted was this idea that
this code wasn't just about the summer
it was going to have to last a really
long time another thing is this black
box you know I would ask Logan hey how
long is it going to take people to
deliver on this project and he'd be like
I just need either six hours or I need
to you know just need a little bit more
time and the thing is that the
experience of having a project that is
that meaty and being able to say I'm
gonna build some predictability and be
able to tell you when I'm actually going
deliver that's actually a skill and it's
really easy to be like oh I just needed
three to four more day you know
especially in school like you can pretty
much solve any problem no one will tell
you this B you can pretty much solve any
problem and like one maybe two
all-nighters right but this was a bigger
project it was really really hard for me
to be like you know what I'm actually
three weeks out wrong pace I think that
especially for internships you know you
either have people swing two ways
they're like I'm waiting for checklists
tell me what to do on a day to day basis
or you have somebody who's Logan who
wants to essentially get his PhD in a
summer and then left field which is
where what we talked about earlier is
don't waiting not waiting for feedback
until the last day these people this is
gonna be a reference and you can ask for
feedback and make sure in the right
track throughout the room throughout
that entire period so that's where we
all were an intern are you guys ready
ready for the next level you yeah we're
feeling good alright so next one oh so
go ahead
so good team member contributor a call
whatever you want oh all right
told you an engineering story so I
thought I'd mix it up and I tell you
something a different type of story I
will have a story
okay so the story comes from a person
who I worked with really really closely
at me Bo and she was on our HR team for
a period of time doesn't really matter
and she came to me and just and we were
talking and she shared this story with
me that has always stuck love the story
um
and so in her very very first role she
was not in HR she was actually in
recruiting and so as a recruiter I
worked with her and I know how amazing
she was let's just for the for the sake
of this let's just call her Lisa I
doesn't really matter I'm like she was
Lisa was just so amazing at detail she
was completely type-a she would just
nail all of the details and in her first
role recruiting was a perfect fit she
was coming in she was creating all of
these job descriptions she was making
sure that everything within the
organization was just so making sure
they weren't hitting any deadlines and
within like three or four years she
decided you know what
the next thing in my in my career is not
going to be moving up but it's going to
be moving to the side and so now instead
of being a recruiter she wanted to jump
into a lateral move on the HR side so if
I'm so as part of that she was
responsible for hiring and training her
replacement who was her peer and so
we're just gonna say peers name was
Margo and Lisa tells me hey listen in
the interview process I was so excited I
love Margo Margo was amazing Margo even
had more years of experience than I did
and I just couldn't imagine a better
person to take my position but then on
day one all of a sudden she realizes
that they have wildly different working
styles and where Lisa was super super
detail-oriented always made sure things
were bright made sure that she
communicated Margo was fast and loose
and was just trying to roll with it
and it was just a completely completely
different working working style and it
came to a head when they were working on
an applicant tracking system now for
anybody else doesn't want a quick a
tracking system it's kind of a fancy way
of saying like a spreadsheet that has
all of your candidate information in it
and it keeps track of
which roles are open which roles aren't
open and Lisa have been working on this
applicant tracking system and she had
almost gotten it at the very very end
she'd been working on it super super
hard and then she's like you know what
you know what the mature thing to do is
I should make sure she gave that project
to Margot as one of her first projects
that she can work on and I should give
that too
she should be the one to roll that out
not me so she did that Margot comes in
and Lisa is like listen this is my baby
I've been reading lists are really
really long time you know there are lots
of things that we still need to think
through but I'm really excited for you
to have it and Margot is like great like
let's just publish that thing right hey
and Margot just wants to immediately
watch it they're a public company she
wants to launch across the entire
organization within her first few days
now from Lisa's perspective she almost
had a heart attack and she's just like I
couldn't even believe it to me like you
know there's so many things we need to
make sure we need to train the team we
need to think we need to double check
that all of the data there we need to
like you know we need to make sure we're
compliant and for me this just seemed
like it was you know she wasn't
respecting what I had done but it was
just like grossly grossly irresponsible
and so Lisa says she goes to her boss
and she says listen you have a problem I
have been you know working with Margot
but Margot is fast and loose
she is disorganized she is not handling
this I think she's been irresponsible I
think things are going to break and
frankly I don't like her and her boss
said to her okay you know first of all I
hear we're coming from I understand
where you're coming from you know I get
it but that feedback would be a lot
better coming from you than from me now
Lisa was already super super stressed
she was already on edge like this was
her baby and when her boss said hey
essentially you know well I think this
is your problem Lisa was just furious so
she is similar somewhere day she goes to
she's at the lunch table and you know
things have been brewing you've been so
tight for so long she's sharing a pizza
with her friends or other colleagues and
she's just like she's like I'm venting
and I'm just like listen you guys I had
to tell you how awful it is to work with
Margo Margo she
understand things she's launching this
18 yes it used to be my baby and I you
know stuff is just gonna go wrong and
there's nothing I can do and I've
already complained in my boss and
nothing has happened it just feels
really awful and you know let's enjoy
this Pete's I feel a lot better having
told you guys this great she goes back
to your cubicle
so then few hours go by and there's a
knock knock knock and she looks up and
who is it it's the CFO the CFO she does
not report to the CFO right
whoever one of her friends at that lunch
table her bosses bosses bosses whatever
did and the course of venting she had
said hey listen we're losing candidates
and one of those candidates actually
reported to the CFO and somehow within
those few hours it got back that because
Margo had launched this ATS they had
lost a candidate just cost in the
process and now the CFO was pretty upset
so the CFO comes he's like hey listen
really really polite just like hey
listen I just wanted you know that hates
yes I just wanted to could I ask you a
few questions and least I said you know
she knew it even though the CFO
completely diplomatic she knew that the
CFO was about to build a case for
letting Margo go and so she's like oh
yeah I come in and so they go through
the 80s and just like hey listen Oh
which Apple hit oh this applicant hears
when the offer was made here's when the
offer went out there's a huge huge huge
disparity the candidate just got lost in
the cracks nobody followed up and that
was ultimately what led them to loose
this really really powerful individual
and so the story Lisa all of a sudden
said that she just feels this wave of
guilt and she's like I had no idea I was
at the lunch table I was just venting I
had no idea they're few hours later this
could potentially end up in having
somebody my former replacement building
a case for letting them go and in the
process of this the CFO was asking your
questions like hey listen you know just
curious why do you feel like we launched
it so quickly why do you feel like we
designed it this way why did we do these
things and the thing is that those
questions were actually really
interesting because all the sudden Lisa
realized that she didn't know the
answers but she wished she did and she
was she had us Margo and she wished she
did have that perspective and now
everything was moving so so so fast
and was going so so so quickly and she
didn't think she could get ahead of it
and she was right so the boss came out
and said hey listen this is my decision
I don't want you to feel guilty about
this but we're gonna let Margaux go and
they did and really really sad and she
still feel guilty about it today she's
written to Margaux she said I apologize
you know and Margo just hasn't ever
talked to her since then and so why am i
sharing this story with you what
mistakes do you hear that could have
been it happened communication in the
workplace definitely holy cow yeah what
else yeah it definitely comes like
management for sure for sure
the interesting thing so I'm gonna go
through a few a few few lessons from
this but the thing is that I actually
have the exact notes from Lisa I have
them here my phone I'm just gonna read
them to you so this is exactly what she
told me I had these notes on my phone I
was saving them for this so now I
realize that her decision to launch the
80s early was actually probably the
right thing to do she wanted to get it
out early and elicit feedback I always
tried to design a perfect system before
rolling it out my strategy probably
meant that I was going to optimize for
problems that didn't exist and I would
have been slow if I had got been able to
get it out at all the mistake around the
approval in the offer was true it's
absolutely true she was disorganized but
in the bigger picture that was a small
issue I took up way too much of my
boss's time complaining about what she
was doing instead of giving her a
helping hand your team is only as good
as your weakest link and I was doing the
team at a service by just complaining
today I hold myself responsible for not
helping and in her final days I got to
know her as a person and I saw she could
have gotten there I also know that I
could have learned from her experience
and I was actually really sad to see her
go in the end okay
so that's emotional journey number two
stay with me BAM now our managers oh boy
all right William William is somebody
that I worked directly with whoa William
William is amazing and I am anonymizing
the details but for all intents and
purposes um William was an engineer he
was an amazing amazing engineer and at
some point we were growing the business
super super super super fast and we
wanted to be able to we needed somebody
to be able to lead the next generation
area team from New York
and William he seemed like the absolute
perfect person to do it
he knew the code everybody loved him he
was just a fantastic engineer he had
been with with the team for a really
really long time and what he was
promoted everybody just applauded we are
so excited now the thing that was tricky
is that we also knew that to be
successful we needed to double if not
triple his team within a year so that
meant hiring that meant writing a Job
Description that meant coming up with a
plan and if you asked William hey listen
you've a choice you can either fix a
super meaty bug you can either figure
out you know the new architecture for
the system or you can work on job
descriptions the job descriptions and
the hiring we're always going to come
last and it's just so hard that
transition right like you've spent years
and years and years learning how to code
and developing these skills then all of
a sudden when you switch from
contributor to manager you have to let
that go and you have to try on a new set
of skills that feels really really
uncomfortable and William we could see
William going through that you know it
was in a really really painful manner
was obvious to everyone else except for
William so it got to a point where we
actually had we knew that we need to be
able to support William and unbeknownst
to him we scheduled this meeting we had
five or six of the most senior people in
the organization there and we're
literally going through the job
descriptions and we're trying to help
him out and we're just like hey listen
when you think about this candidate and
I can see him and he's just
like oh yeah maybe maybe maybe but it's
just not clicking now he didn't report
to me he reported to a director and I
had worked with William I believed he
would step up to the plate I wasn't
really concerned but a few weeks later
many many many many weeks later the road
director came to me and he said hey
listen I think I'm going to have to let
William go I was just like whoa whoa
whoa whoa I love William Williams
amazing right like what happened and he
started to tell me the story he's just
like listen
William is supposed to you know we have
to make sure like I have people coming
to me you know they're saying that the
team is overstretch they can't get
things out and a few weeks ago I went to
William head I said William gotta start
hiring you've gotta start working on
your job description she's got to start
I need you to step up I need you to
manage and William was like I get it I
get it I get it and then the next week
you know they'd be talking what projects
are you working on and he was working on
some code who's working on some Susteren
sod she's like oh but how are those job
descriptions and Williams like oh yeah I
have I have a few new ideas though a few
new ideas next week next week next week
so got to the point where next week next
week next week you know the director is
stressed it's like wow you know like I I
promoted you and now I put a lot of
trust in you and I'm beginning to regret
that because this is seriously
jeopardizing our business so then he
tries tactic number one he says William
next week I need you to show me a plan I
need you to show me the hiring plan and
I want it to say what rules are we
hiring when I want you to tell me you
know which which one are you going to
hire for first what's their first
project going to be how many do we need
to do when is it going to land and I
want to make sure that we are both on
the same page about this hiring plan and
I want to see it next week Oh Ames like
okay sounds good and so the next week
came they're having their one-on-one and
they're talking and it's like okay great
like how's it going and Williams like
it's going really really well and he's
like okay great but where's the plan and
we almost like oh I haven't done it I'm
really really really really sorry I know
that was super super important but I
just haven't done it there's been so
many other things that's um on the back
seat and the director said he almost
lost it he was just like oh my gosh like
I really this was kind of my like trying
to give him yet another another
opportunity and he said at that point
he'd already lost all patience but he
slept it off he was just like what are
we going to do
and so few days later he tapped William
any sec let's go on a walk
he's like William you have seriously
jeopardize the business I don't think
you even understand the impact this is
having right like the fact that you
haven't done this hiring plan I
specifically asked for it this is one of
the most critical initiatives in the
entire organization you may not feel it
now but in a year this is going to have
serious consequences and Williams said
yes yes yes I hear you
I'm really really sorry you know I
really am excited about this opportunity
I want to do well I you know well I'll
try even harder and the director said
it's too late for that like I don't
think you understand but I have come up
with like let's just start start clean
and what I've done is I have worked in
my network and I found this external
recruiter somebody it's personal friend
and I have found the budget and I'm
going to pair her with you and your
entire all she is responsible is for you
helping you build out this team so this
is I understand let's you know water
under the bridge let bygones be bygones
this is a brand new fresh slate we're
gonna get things right we're gonna get
things on the right path giving you the
resources that you need but I need you
to hire I need you to actually spend
time hiring and so the William so wait
so weekly weeks go by and the director
is going off doing his meetings and he
gets an email and it gets an email and
it's from not William with the external
recruiter the external recruiter says
hey listen I'm just touching base you
know you introduced us a while ago but I
just want you to know that ever since
then William just doesn't respond to
emails this hasn't gone anywhere right
and it's just like holy cow and so at
that point that's when we had to start
talking about what are the next steps
and eventually we ended up moving
William into a into a senior role senior
engineering role and eventually hiring
another leader to be in that spot but
the thing that's many many years go by
and I'm like William you know like I
know you and you don't report directly
to me but I want to hear what happened
right like what's the story like I got
all of this insight from the director
but that just I know you and it doesn't
sound like you what actually happened
and so the story and what I think is
really interesting is that when I was
hearing the story from Williams
perspective he's like you know what at
the time that wasn't what I was hearing
at all so I I know that we're having
I knew that the director was really
really really really mad at me and I
knew things weren't going right but I
never heard hey I just need to focus on
hiring and I know that that boggles your
mind but it is true and when I look at
that when I said like okay well what do
you think happened he's like I really at
the time I was like I just don't think
the director wants me here I don't think
he likes me I feel like he feels like
I'm getting in the way of doing what he
really wants and he wants to you know
build the team in this particular
direction that's not how I want to build
the team and he said from then on he
realized that whenever he got feedback
first he was internalizing it but
whenever he got feedback from then on
especially from somebody who is a senior
he realized that he really needed to
focus he was hearing feedback he wasn't
sure at the time was this he's hearing
you know there's lots of things that the
director is upset about and he realized
that if he doesn't understand something
he needs to be able to identify whether
this is an anthill or whether it is a
mountain and when they were having their
one-on-one conversations to him the
urgency and the severity of it you know
he's just listening to hear there are 20
things that the directors asked for and
he didn't realize you know why are they
talking about in the last five minutes
why weren't they talking about it from
the beginning right and he just didn't
understand that he was supposed to drop
everything and spend 80% of his time
just doing hiring so what are the
mistakes here all right so yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly exactly and I
think this is tendency whenever you go
especially from the contributor to the
manager level instead of adapting and
taking on a new set of skills your
inclination is just to become a super
contributor and you're like I'm gonna
solve everything by being faster by
doing all these things but when you need
to double the output of your company you
know it's not going to happen just by
you pulling a few all-nighters right
that's really the main thing also
thinking short term not necessarily long
term he really needed to be he was doing
all this coding but he wasn't
necessarily thinking about how to be
able to plan for the successful career
of his team and then it was just like
the feedback they were just operating on
totally different channels right and he
wasn't hearing it he wasn't hearing the
urgency he wasn't asking follow-up
questions and being like wow like what
am I not understanding here this is not
going I know that this is not going the
way I think it should but what's really
happening awesome you guys ready
director oh here we are now the director
role attractor role always ends up in
such sneaking up on me and I love
managing teams some why managing chains
then all of a sudden it's just like oh
Elaine can you manage another team like
sure that sounds awesome I love hitting
goals
I love figuring out how are we gonna
prioritize things super super fun and
then all of a sudden somebody's like oh
and at the same time can you land this
huge media initiative that like involves
both of your teams and then I'm like oh
shoot now I'm a director right so the
story that I want to tell whoops whoops
the story that I want to tell is a story
from a an engineer that I know and she
had grown into a director role and she
was responsible she was at a start-up
and she was responsible for overseeing a
product team an engineering team lots of
different roles and her startup at that
time had the opportunity to potentially
get a fortune 500 client so first it was
a make-or-break deal just like holy cow
this calling it says that if we build
such-and-such they will switch from our
competitor to using our tool this has a
huge signaling value this could be a
turnaround moment for our organization I
cannot wait for you to build this
and so the director let's just call her
Emily Emily it looks like great got it
everybody's so excited and they're
people who are excited because I think
it's going to generate money they're
it's going to have tons of press they're
people who are excited because it's just
a really interesting engineering problem
but she's just like you know what like I
heard the feedback I knew we had to get
started on this and so the first thing I
did was I just like was just like let's
just get they you know I'm gonna deal
with all the feedback in turn but let's
just get this thing rolling let's just
keep going
so she starts building it and a few you
know I think they have like five or six
months to build it and around month two
or three she's taking her initial
prototype and she goes to the fortune
500 clients she says hey you know I'm so
excited I want to get your feedback
we're so excited to work with you thank
you for this opportunity I'm really
excited I wanted to make sure you got
feedback early all those things and the
client says well this is great
but why doesn't it integrate with our
database and Emily is just like what
what what database right like nobody
told me we had to integrate with the
database database it's gonna take us
like two to three more months of work no
one said this to me she doesn't say that
to the client but she'd go back to her
VP and CEO and she's just like listen
like you know if you have conversations
with a client or you've had
conversations and there's something we
have to implement you need to tell me
because otherwise you know I'm not going
to be able to have the team and be able
to build this for you and so CEO it's
like yeah we could have handled that
better we could have given you more
feedback early on the VP is like yeah
but you know I really appreciate you're
just rolling with that I'm so excited
this is kind of alright startup day is
crazy I'm just like yeah okay that's
fine that's fine you know what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to build the world's
most beautiful plan and I'm gonna show
you exactly how much time it's going to
take to be able to build every single
feature and I just want to make sure
that we're all on the same page because
if we have any other surprises I don't
know and she went to our VP and she's
like you know see this plan if we have
any more surprises like crazy idea a
free trial experience you know something
crazy out of the moon I want to make
sure that you know that we just we can't
do it and we need just be able to say no
you guys know where this is going right
yeah so they're building it they've done
a really really great job and all of a
sudden it's a week before their deadline
is supposed to happen and the CEO the VP
is there's this high-level management
meeting everybody comes out and her VP
comes straight to her
and he says hey Emily right like try
remember I know we had this conversation
a while ago and the CEO was asking I
can't remember typically just suck we're
gonna do the free trial experience or
not and Emily's just like holy cow like
literally the one conversation I did not
want to have happen right we talked
about this we both agreed that we
weren't going to have any more features
and the future that I said that I was
just making up in that moment that I
absolutely did not want to do was free
trial experience and so she's like we
can't do that that's doesn't make any
sense like that's gonna be so hard to
implement she called in her engineer and
she's like engineer please tell her VP
why arnis is so hard and why we can't do
this in the engineer tried and the VP is
like yeah but RC it really needs it
that's what we need to do and so in a
week they built the world's worst free
trial experience ever and they launched
with it and what do you think happened
yeah didn't work right it crashed and
burned you know there was it was not the
successful they had done so much work
and then the last week the week where
they should have been working on bugs
they should have been working on all
these other things hey you know the free
trial how do you get somebody to use a
buggy product off of the really really
buggy free trial user experience like
this does not add up right so if you go
to Emily and you say Emily what happened
there right what do you feel like the
mistakes might be oh yes yes that's
absolutely right she was said that she
wasn't necessarily thinking about the
you know especially in the director role
you really have to be thinking about
your managing your peers your managing
the people underneath you and you are
managing the people above you and
especially for director role you are
right in the thick of it absolutely
that's that's that's a pretty much the
the number one of it but the the other
thing I want to point out here is that
for directors where they are really
trying to figure out exactly like the
director role it's where the strategy
hits the road and they are responsible
for taking these high-level initiatives
and turning them in articulating them
into a feasible plan and the number one
problem that I see directors have is
this feeling of leap they're always
complaining about a crazy VP thought the
crazy VP came to me and the crazy VP
said this huge major initiative the week
not do and I felt like in that moment I
only had two choices I could either say
no and look weak or I could say yes but
I knew that we were going to ultimately
fail and so it's like which one do you
choose in that moment but the truth is
that what was really happening is the VP
and the director we're not using the
same language the VP totally rational
person he wants the company to do well
but when when Emily was going to him and
saying this is really really complex the
VP wasn't hearing this is this is going
to throw off all of our strategy so what
you needed to do is say hey listen I
understand this is really important and
if you want this to be successful you
want us to hit our numbers then maybe we
need to talk about whether something
needs to go I need more budget I need
more people I make whatever and be able
to have a communication at the VP have a
conversation at the VP's level cool
great all right emotional journey are
you ready for the next one we're getting
down to the very very end Oh awesome
thank you so um I'm gonna talk about the
VP the VP story it's the pivot I'll
charge everyone this just briefly and
they'll move on to the final thing I
want to talk about within me beau we had
one thing that we've always wanted to do
and that was we always wanted to make
sure we had a plan B and so we're always
really really good about this we for
those of you not familiar with Bebo we
were on the back of a Mira madad all
these other things and we knew that we
could be turned off at any second and so
we originally said hey listen if all
else goes we can always be open source
at one point when we thought aim was
potentially going to release a
competitor we actually like ended up
building a copy of the entire social
their social graph so that we could
launch something that was a competitor
overnight and then at the very very bit
in the three to four years and you end
up in this point where in an
organization you need to be able to
deliver on your promises to your
investors and we need to be able to
deliver on profitability and in this
point we thought we had a plan B which
was we were really really excited
because her plan B was going to be we
were also building mobile at the same
time if we needed to switch over we
could and we built this amazing we swung
hard we said we're gonna go from chat to
advertising platform because we wanted
to own our own destiny we wanted to be
little generate revenue and if we had
revenue would make everything else
easier and built it worked on it for I
don't know 12 18 months and then the
market slipped and in q4
which is the biggest advertising quarter
of them all all of a sudden it was the
first time when we really had to
implement or Plan B and then we had kind
of a plan behave in our in our pocket
where was like mobile and all these
other things what we realized at that
point and what I realized at that point
was that the plan B was there but the
team was not and I had spent all his
time doing all of the strategy and
thinking through things and we built
this entire organization around this new
idea of advertising platform we wanted
to be able to innovate we wanted to be
able to go to next things but the people
who have been responsible for the
innovation who are part of a really core
DNA they'd order left the organization
they were no longer in the right roles
and from that point even though I really
wanted to build a be nimble and be able
to move and be able to pivot again I had
built an organization that was probably
going to take another two to three years
be able to get to the point where I'd be
able to have that again and so that's
the the the reason I share that story is
because typically whenever you're at
that point in a startup there's this
tendency to swing really really you
build up a product and then you swing
really really really really hard to be
able to meet your first deliverables to
be able to deliver profitability and you
forget that once you achieve that you're
probably going to need to have more Rd
and you're gonna be able to need to be
able to innovate again and if you swing
too hard and you omit some of those
really wonderful key initial players you
may not have that plan B you should have
gotten more buy-in from the organization
overall so that's a that's a really
really really really short version of it
I think I think maybe I should I really
want to read the the CEO story but seven
minute oh yeah I could totally do it all
right yeah Pete
I was over optimized brother optimized
for numbers and then I sure change us a
little bit more do we have buy-in team
wants to do what is right but we just we
didn't have the organization I had I had
the strategy but I didn't have the team
to do it and I wasn't thinking ahead at
that level o sea level oh I'm so excited
I got you this one okay okay okay
so final days so this is not this is the
story shared to me by a friend it's
really really personable and I feel
really really honored to have it and I
asked him he was this the CEO he was a
startup and he was a founder and CEO of
a public company and I asked and he
after they IPO - he ended up stepping
down and now he does investing he does
lots of great things
but I just like tell me about how you
knew it was time and so he said you know
like when you're doing a startup and
you've been there from the very very
very very beginning you are always
trying to get to the point where you
have a successful and you've a
sustainable company and we have worked
for years and years to get there and
this moment when we finally achieved it
and I could feel it he's like it was
like an adrenaline high like no other
I've ever experienced and when he was at
that peak he's just like we did it
I can't imagine ever leaving this
organization this is where I'm going to
be for my entire life like there was no
world in which he could ever imagine
himself not being part of of this team
fast forward a little bit you know one
of the things the CEO is you always are
working on things that your team doesn't
have time for and so its first started
off where he's working on some HR tasks
then he's trying to work with his CFO to
be able to build a dashboard that
capture some random finance thing and he
said it doesn't wasn't something where
you know he's being in the startup is
tons of highs and tons of lows but he
got to a point where he realized that he
had had a lot of blah faces and
specifically after all of this he woke
up and he was in his hotel room he had
been traveling doing all these
conference of speaking things meeting
with partners and he would realize that
he hadn't left his hotel room in four to
five days and he's just suddenly looked
at all the papers around him and was
just like is this really what I want to
be doing and all the things that he
really enjoyed doing like working on a
product and working on the engineering
it wasn't you know those things still
existed but it wasn't under his purview
anymore and he realized hey listen I'm
not sure you like it was just the
inkling of like maybe this isn't
actually where I want to be long term so
he went to his board and he said listen
not doing anything right now but I just
want to ask you you know just trying to
figure out how I feel and the nice thing
about his position is that all of his
board members have been previous CEOs
and they got it and they said perfect
they delivered the perfect response
which just was like I hear you I know
this is hard
really appreciate where you've been been
from I've been there too and there have
been times where I thought you know what
maybe this is the beginning of the end
and I've been wrong and there have been
time so I thought maybe this is the
beginning of the end and I've been right
and what I want you to do is I want you
to in your head start imagining a future
in which you stay and start imagining a
future in which you go and I want you to
start thinking about who your successor
would be
how you would get there and start
planning for it and then in six months
see which future feels better for you
and so he did and he originally thought
hey listen my CEO is definitely gonna be
my number two successor I'm so excited
and he realized actually maybe not and
he got really really lucky he said that
was his biggest mistake he got really
really lucky where he was able to find a
number two but it was just a fluke and
he just got super super lucky and so
then that was it and so he left and that
was the end of his stark journey so I've
given you all six different levels here
you know no succession planning is the
thing I want to touch upon for sea level
the sea level it's such an intense
experience the work/life balance it's
you know humans are not physically
capable of enduring the sea level role
for too long and then also at the very
end being left with the crumbs not real
not having projects that really excited
him anymore so with that I'm gonna go to
Q&A what do we have what what questions
do you have yeah absolutely thank you
he's asking hey for founder's she jumped
immediately into a via sea level are
they missing something out and the thing
is that regardless of what my title was
my title was like you know co-founder
and I was leading this the product team
and leading the front end engineering
team so from the very beginning I had a
sea title but what I was actually doing
in a day-to-day was very very different
and so I would say from a founders
perspective if you're really a founder
regardless of what your title is you
kind of have to start at the ground
level and build your way up yeah other
questions
yeah I definitely weren't like the first
whenever I switched into a new role I
had two or three weeks where I was just
like I used to be good at what I did and
now I'm not and it took me two to three
weeks to feel what the organization
needed so what like it was not a natural
progression at all I was just like oh my
gosh like yesterday was doing
such-and-such now I'm in this new role
and I had to get used to it yep
really question what was it like to
transition from tech to a completely
different company like dandelion
chocolate I think that there were things
that were really lovely about
transitioning to dandelion chocolate
which was I felt like whenever I was in
the engineering world in the tech world
everybody has this very concrete sense
of how things should go and when I moved
into a completely different industry I
felt like I had tremendous freedom and
flexibility to test things out
especially in an organization level and
do things that I hadn't done before that
was super exciting at the other hand
release cycles at a Chocolate Factory
are a little bit slower than in the
engineering world so that was definitely
like something to think about
yeah the question would Wendy decide to
move up or when you decide to stay and I
would say that as a founder you really
don't have much choice because you know
you just rise to whatever occasion that
the organization needs from you and
sometimes you're not good at it and
that's you know it's frustrating but
it's okay there were definitely time so
I'm like okay I wasn't very good at that
but I'm better at this level and that's
good yep final question
okay yep from the very very back notice
on the beauty slider the points was that
it's important to have as you know life
even if you're not sure it's the right
course this attention that you see
between trying to get in alignment if
you think it's better versus doing
something that's more of a consensus
view and I think it's a great question
and when I talk to other when I thank
you when I talk to it so the question
was how important is it to get consensus
versus kind of doing what you think is
the most important is that a good or yep
service right so driving towards what
you think is the right consensus versus
actually getting consensus there's
another store that I don't know how time
to share which I feel like orchestrates
this very very well where it's from a
CEO comes in to a start-up and has to
figure out what are we gonna do next
and he's just like I feel like this is
where we definitely need to go but the
team just came back from South by
Southwest and all they want to do is
build such-and-such and he's just like I
don't know if that's the right thing to
do but it was just like mentally I know
it's going to take me at least 12 months
to be able to get the entire team onto
this versus we can just start building
this thing that the team really wants to
build after South by Southwest and even
if it's the wrong direction at least
we're all aligned we haven't been
aligned
for and I know we can course correct to
be able to get to where I think we need
to go long term cool that's everything